[knocks]
- Hey, guys!
Come on in!
Take your shoes off. Relax.
No, seriously.
Remove your shoes
and put them in
the designated cubbies, please.
This place is probably
really aspiration for you guys,
but if you work hard enough,
one day,
you too could have
a luxury pre-9/11 style
condominium with optional,
built-in shelving.
- Is that the clock?
- Yep, that's the one.
But, uh, before we get to that,
I would love to give
you two the tour.
- Oh--
- No.
- This is the bedroom.
Pretty standard.
Uh, I like to kind of peek out
the windows and spy on
my neighbors here a little bit.
This controls the temperature
in the room for the most part.
I'm sure you guys are familiar
with that technology.
[eerie tone]
- [whispers]
Where's the bed?
♪ ♪
- Don't ask questions
you don't want the answer to.
- And this is my bird room.
[shimmering tone]
Hi.
Yes.
I missed you, too.
[imitates bird cawing]
- [whistles]
- Matt, please don't do that.
You'll confuse them.
[sighs]
And here is the reason
you're here.
Isn't she a beaut?
Wait, it's a--
it's a grandfather clock
so he's a beaut.
You know what, guys,
let's not gender the clock.
Okay?
It's a beaut.
- So where are we moving
this genderless beaut?
- [pops tongue]
- [sighs]
- On three--
one, two, lift.
[both groaning]
- Good.
Lift with your knees, Matt.
With your knees.
Lift with your knees, please.
Please don't scratch
the leather.
That is real.
Okay. Thread that needle.
Yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup,
yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup,
and yup.
If you guys wanna
get out of the way for a second.
Ooh!
I don't know, it's a--
Slide back in for one second.
I just wanna--here.
Is that it?
I'm watching TV.
What time is it?
I'm not wearing my watch.
Oh, it's 3:30.
Uh, you know what,
it's pretty helpful
to see it in context.
Do, like, you're just--
it's, like, a dinner party,
and you're a little tired,
and you're a vegetarian.
You guys are just chatting.
- It's nice being here
at this dinner party,
but I guess I'm just
a little tired.
- I can't eat any of
the meat stuff.
- Mmm.
So you guys came over
to watch the game.
Your team won, your team lost,
but it's just sort of
something to talk about.
- Well, it's great news
that my team won the game.
- Well, my team lost so I'm mad.
- Uh, I'm on the fence.
Man, I'm pissed my team lost!
- So you're at
a breakfast party,
and you both want
the last biscuit.
- Oh, I thought that I--
did you want it?
- I mean, I've had a couple,
but I thought--
- I haven't had
any biscuits thus far.
- You've been waiting up
all night for him to come home.
- It's 2:00 a.m.
and you smell like perfume.
What the hell?
[snaps fingers]
I got it!
Okay, lift on three.
One, two, lift.
[both groaning]
Yup, come on this way.
Jake, with your knees, buddy.
Turn it, turn it, turn it.
Keep going--please be careful,
Matt, for God's sake.
Yeah.
[jazzy music]
Perfect.
Sometimes, you gotta go
all the way around the world
to realize that home...
[pops tongue]
Is the only place you wanna be.
[chuckles]
- I got a splinter.
- Thank you guys so much.
- Ow!
- I really appreciate it.
- God.
- Thank you for helping me out.
As a thank you,
you have to let me take you
to dinner.
- That's really nice
of you to offer,
but I'm not really
much of an eater.
- I just don't eat.
- I am taking you guys to dinner
I will not take no
for an answer.
Plus, you gotta get
your parking validated.
Not cheap.
I'll grab your shoes
from the cubbies.
[both inhale]
[both sigh]
both: Fuck.